praise the Lord Tuesday has come and
with it new video game news including
the announcement of Dragon Quest 11 the
announcement was made during a special
live stream where it was also revealed
that the ps4 version will be built on
Unreal Engine for the Nintendo 3ds
version meanwhile seems to be developed
in collaboration with a third-party
studio interestingly the 3ds version
displays the game in a modern visual
style akin to the nintendo DS entries in
the series while the bottom screen takes
a top-down visual style reminiscent of
earlier nes games a presentation of the
battles will also be styled
appropriately to match the two visual
styles no announcement was made on
release in territories outside of Japan
but with gamescom fast approaching we
expect Square Enix to have more details
to share soon during the stream Square
Enix also announced Dragon Quest 10 an
MMORPG entry in the series from 2012
that will now be released on PlayStation
4 in Japan the game was previously only
available for Wii U 3ds and PC although
Square Enix confirm Dragon Quest 11 and
Dragon Quest 10 will be released on
Nintendo and X it did not provide any
specific details on those versions of
the game well three years after its
release Dragon Quest 7 for the 3ds has
still not come out North America nor has
Dragon Quest 8 which came out almost a
year ago to the day and are reading at
these stateside who knows probably not
or maybe let me know in the comments
below and for more news stay tuned and
gamespot com